retour en bourgogne pour cette soirée
spéciale élections départementales sur
france 3 vous allez tous à voir avec les
premiers résultats qui arrive en ce
moment même nous les détaillants avec
elle a besoin vous retrouvez également
ses résultats sur notre site internet
france3 point fr nous les détaillerons
nous les expliquerons nous décrypterons
avec quelle lilian melet et eric sicaud
également des invités nous ont rejoints
pour l'ump le député de côte-d'or
alain suguenot bonsoir alain suguenot et
françois patriat est avec nous pour le
parti socialiste président de la région
bourgogne pour expliquer également ses
résultats des résultats donc il ça
arrive depuis mâcon nous retrouvons des
amis un bouteille en préfecture de mâcon
premiers résultats définitifs pour le
département de saône-et-loire à damien
effectivement ça commence à tomber avec
déjà un premier binôme élu ça se passe
du côté de chauffailles marie-christine
bignon et arnaud du riz sont élus avec
53,79 % et puis il y en a un autre qui
est passé à très très près ce soir c'est
à paray-le-monial c'est le binôme d'
andré accary et carole chenu et
pardonnez moi qui font que 52 78 % des
exprimés mais ils ne font que 19 points
75 % des inscrits ils voulons que se
retrouver pour un deuxième tour avec
stéphanie gâteau et louis poncet du
parti socialiste voilà et puis nous
commençons également à avoir des
triangulaires dans le département
notamment du côté du ring où gérard
collomb et marie thérèse drevet de l'ump
feront face à catherine fargeau et andré
plaie pour le ps et alain cognard et
audrey richard pour le front national à
noter qu'entre le ps et l'ump il y a
deux petites voix d'écart
autres triangulaires du côté de chagny
c'est claudette brunet lechenault qui
arrive en tête avec 30,68 % suivi par le
front national philippe soulié et sa
colistière 30 0 3%
et puis l'union départementale madame
darphin cécile et sébastien laurent
28,89 dans les duels les duels je dirais
assez classique le creusot gauche-droite
32,10 pognon de la gauche avec laurence
mort soit et bernard durand suivi de
près par les divers droite marie france
ferries et gilles signol 27,91 % autre
duel c'est à mâcon en faveur de l'ump
39,66 % des voix pour claude canet et
hervé reynaud talonné par le ps 29,17
rodolphe martin et catherine ndiaye
enfin saint vallier est toujours un duel
avec lda berger qui arrive en tête et
alain philibert 27,5 face au parti
socialiste hélène go fichons et jean
claude lagrange 26,59 % merci d'amiens
pour ces premiers résultats
première tendance lilian melet sur la
saône et loire très difficile de dégager
des tendances de ce qu'on entend parce
qu'on est essentiellement sur des
cantons on va dire qu'ils ne sont pas
décisifs dans une éventuelle bascule du
département de saône et loire
pas grand chose à retenir si ce n'est
qu'on n'a pas vu pour l'instant si je ne
m'abuse de front national qui serait
présent deuxième tour uniquement avec le
ps ou uniquement avec l'ump quand le
front national est présent c'est dans le
cadre de triangulaire ça correspond à
peu près aux résultats nationaux qu'on
commence à voir edouard ferrand vient
d'arriver sur ce plateau pendant que je
parlais sur la position du front
national qui situerait plutôt dans
certaines estimations troisième position
ce soir il ya un des 1 un canton qui est
intéressant rapidement c'est celui de
saint vallier qui étaient détenus pour
partie par le parti communiste avec
alain philibert dans ce canton c'est un
petit peu étonnant la gauche a
extrêmement bien
résister puisque on va trouver jean
claude lagrange l'ancien président de la
communauté urbaine qui situant au
deuxième tour avec le parti communiste
au premier tour donc là on voit une
gauche qui a résisté sur un endroit qui
est véritablement un fief absolue ça ne
signifie pas du tout ça va se passer
comme ça dans d'autres cantons bien sûr
du département et de la région
nous partons pour renault vers des
résultats arriverait là aussi en direct
de la préfecture de nevers
régis lions nous attend quels sont les
résultats à votre disposition à cette
heure-ci
eh bien écoutez d'après nos informations
pas encore de binômes élus sur l'un des
17 cantons que compte la nièvre j'ai là
le résultat les résultats de sept
cantons je vais aller à l'essentiel est
d'abord vous parlez de château chinon il
y aura un duel ps fn
le président du conseil général sortant
sur ce canton de château chinon patrice
joly arrive en tête avec 37 10 % des
voix il est suivi d'assez près
finalement par le binôme fn harold
delanoë et et isabelle pas qu'avec le 32
35% voilà duels ps fn sur château chinon
la semaine prochaine un autre canton
assez emblématique de la gauche ici dans
le département de la nièvre c'est celui
de corby n'y avait que le sortant et
vice président du conseil général fabien
bazin et bien fabien bazin arrive 2e 2e
il est effectivement devancé par le
binôme incarné par jean charles rechard
le binôme de droite voilà la droite en
programmant tête pardon la droite en
tête sur corner qui suivit pas revivre
la nièvre le ps et ses alliés de la
gauche
je passe à nevers de nevers de là c'est
un peu la surprise puisque c'est le fn
qui arrive en tête nevers de ses sept
cantons qui s'étend de saint-éloi
magny-cours et christophe gaillard le
conseiller municipal front national de
nevers arrive en tête devant donc la
candidate de la gauche la candidate
sortante
delphine fleury et son binôme vivre la
nièvre donc là aussi un duel à suivre la
semaine prochaine le canton maintenant
reste à nevers le canton de nevers
quatre là c'est le ps qui arrive en tête
et il y aura un duel avec le mouvement
nièvre à venir nier
à venir c'est un peu l'émanation de ne
verra ni de nevers à venir qui avait
créé denis thuriau le maire actuel de
nevers il a décidé de décliner son
inverse à venir vous le savez en oeuvre
à venir avec quelques binôme comme ça
parsemées sur la nièvre est bien là il y
aura sur le canton de nevers 4 un duel
donc ps et nièvre à venir je passe au
canton d'imphy là un duel aussi entre le
ps et le fn le fn arrivé en deuxième
position et le ps arrivé en première
position bien sûr avec daniel barbier
notamment le le conseiller général
sortant et et joël julien la mère d'un
fils justement donc là aussi un duel ps
fn
je passe à luzy où on penser
qu'effectivement une élection pouvait
avoir lieu au premier tour et que le
mièvre à venir donc le la l'étiquette
pardon un des ddd sortant du département
et de leurs alliés de la gauche pouvait
s'imposer dès le premier tour c'est pas
le cas
nièvre à venir neuf par dont l'étiquette
pardon vivre la nièvre on s'y perd
presque un vivre la nièvre donc bien on
devra devra se battre au deuxième tour
contre une justement des sans étiquette
voilà donc là aussi sur le canton usine
où on avait compris un duel la semaine
prochaine et puis j'en termine avec un
prénom j'ai fini je revenais sur sur
nevers 2 voilà comment on vous tient au
courant des résultats ce qu'on peut
noter ces cassettes or s'il n'y a encore
pas deux binômes élus ici dans le
département de la nièvre
merci régis guyot en direct de nevers
vous le comprenez les résultats arrivent
eux en temps réel et où nous vous les
deux noms dès qu'ils arrivent également
en préfecture lilian melet sur cette
situation dans la nièvre avec des
surprises alors un premier point on
parlait du canton du morvan canton de
château chinon canton historique puisque
c'est pour partie canton de françois
mitterrand il faut rappeler que patrice
joly qui était précédemment le
conseiller général du canton de montceau
qui a été intégrée dans ce canton au
deuxième tour en 2011 il avait déjà
affronté le front national au deuxième
tour on a dans les zones rurales de la
nièvre à front national qui est déjà
élevé depuis un certain temps et ça se
confirme ya en revanche une nouveauté
qu'on a commencé à entendre concernant
les cantons nevers d'abord c'est quand
même la réussite d'un certain nombre de
candidats estampillés est marqué par
denis thuriau le nouveau maire de nevers
l'un de ses candidats sur le canton de
nevers
4 philippe morel c'est quelqu'un que
ceux qui ont été le président du conseil
régional il s'y connaît puisqu'il a été
content conseiller régional précédemment
sous les couleurs de l'udf à l'époque au
conseil régional de bourgogne et puis on
voit un front national qui est élevé sur
les cantons de nos verres c'est la suite
des élections municipales ça préfigure
peut-être quand même des difficultés
pour les candidats socialistes sur la
ville de nevers dans l'élan de cette
municipale perdue
là encore il est un peu tôt pour savoir
si ça peut préfigurer une difficulté de
majorité pour le ps sur le conseil
général de la nièvre le canton de
corbigny quand même avec fabien bazin
ses emblématiques aussi de cette gauche
rural qui a du mal face au front
national dans la nièvre
on va le voir dans la suite si ça se
confirme il aimait une autre inconnue
c'était la vitesse à laquelle les
résultats les nous parvenir avec ces
cantons plus important que lors des
dernières cantonales dont on sait
départementale eh bien ces résultats
arrive apparemment nous allons partir
pour audi jean dijon la préfecture de
dijon nous attend lise régie avec là
aussi des résultats lisent sur ce
département
oui quatre résultats pour quatre cantons
dont on connaît là aussi l'enjeu en tout
cas pas de binômes et lui non plus ici
pour l'instant celui qui peut vous
donner déjà c'est celui de beaune où on
va assister un duel un canton de beaune
plus d'ordinaire plutôt acquis à la
droite et bien ça se confirme avec 20
points 90 % pour jean pierre rebourgeon
et marie-laure rakic et puis ça passe
aussi au second tour pour le front
national donc avec mathieu tillier et
eléonore points en revanche est bien le
les socialistes sont écartés de ce tour
là on va ensuite regarder ce qui se
passe alors du côté d'arnay-le-duc cette
fois ci parce que l'enjeu là aussi est
important triangulaire dans ce canton
d'arnay-le-duc la gauche qui joue gros
dans ce canton immense et bien les
socialistes sont en tête le tandem
béatrice monjoin air marie et pierre
poillot avec 18,0 8% suivi là aussi par
le front national
rené lioret delphine schlegel à 15,91 %
des inscrits et puis enfin triangulaire
et bien là c'est l'union de la droite
emmenée par claude courront et jérôme
soupart donc triangulaire pour ce canton
d'arnay-le-duc on va voir que ces 10 cas
également
j'en reprends mes feuilles pour le
canton de nuits-saint-georges là aussi
où on assiste à une triangulaire des
résultats extrêmement serrés entre le
premier tandem de l'union de la droite
valérie dureuil et hubert poullot et
puis également donc le front national
qui arrive à 18,0 6% juste derrière non
pardon l'union de la gauche
marie christine garnier et pierre
alexandre privolt et puis donc le front
national en troisième position
richard andré et françoise mulot voilà
pour les résultats pour pour ces
triangulaire la noter enfin que du côté
de ladoix serrigny eh bien on assiste
cette fois ci à un duel l'union de la
droite en tête
anne parent denis thomas 23,65 % pour ce
premier tour et là aussi c'est un duel
avec l'extrême droite le front national
noël trade et cindy david et 15,64 % la
gauche est exclue de ce premier tour
dans ce canton de ladoix serrigny merci
les sujets depuis la préfecture de
côte-d'or a dit jean alain suguenot
on a évoqué va dans votre fief le logo
de moi le sud de la côte d'or et la côte
d'or en général votre réaction sur ce
département principalement ce soir je
retiens pas de grosse surprise puisque
concrètement je pense que l'une dure de
l'ump et ses alliés
en tête à part effectivement sur le
canton d'arnay-le-duc mais faudra delluc
rappelez vous ce sont quatre cantons et
demi qui a été tenue par la gauche donc
concrètement qu'il ya aujourd'hui une
triangulaire sur ce territoire que le
front national soit là où idem mais
c'est pas non plus une grosse surprise
dans le contexte même des
départementales bonne ça doit faire en
pourcentage 51% pour marie laure acquis
qu avec la foi seule à 24%
donc le la gauche effectivement ne peut
pas se maintenir vous l'avez rappelé et
sur le canton autrefois de de baudre
rural disant je l'appelle sales blancs
d'oeuf par rapport aux jaunes d'oeuf
c'est ça c'est un peu ridicule dire
s'explique certainement aussi le
désarroi book de beaucoup d'électeurs a
pas de surprise non plus je pense que le
dit thomas est très largement en tête et
donc dans ces conditions il ya surprise
à deuxième tour avec un front national
qui est second mais la gauche et élimine
également de ce territoire à front
national qui est second et qui moins
élevé que ce qu'on pouvait penser dans
certains secteurs
oui tout à fait je crois que c'est bien
la confirmation de ce que l'union fait
la force et que encodeur on le verra
d'ailleurs sur d'autres territoires
parce qu'on est déjà quelques résultats
je pense que l'union de l'ump du déni
aujourd'hui sera probablement dimanche
prochain parce qu'on a vu qu'il y avait
quand même beaucoup de triangulaire
dimanche près ça sera en tête bien sûr
et gagnera à certain nombre de cantons
je pense que c'était déjà prévisible est
différent une réaction à ce qu'on vient
de dire un front national qui serait
peut-être pas aussi haut qui ne sera pas
le premier parti de france après les
européennes
alors mais d'abord je remercie tous les
électeurs qui ont participé justement à
ce vote civique parce que l'abstention
finalement a pas été aussi faible
qu'avancé
je pense qu'il ya eu un sursaut un
sursaut patriotes
le front national est le premier parti
de france si on additionne les voix de
l'ump de lui des idées divia droite bien
évidemment mais je crois qu'il faut pas
masquer les choses c'est à dire que
l'ump est derrière le front national au
surpoids nationale en bourgogne vraiment
les estimations
c'est tout fortement pour l'instant
aucune confusion si les alliés de l'ump
étaient largement devant voilà sa voix
la droite est plus forte en ce qui
concerne la bogoss sur un plan sur un
plan général on multiplie à peu près par
par trois nos résultats je trouve que
c'est quand même une très bonne
progression
y'a pas de triomphalisme on est
optimiste je crois que entrer dans les
conseils départementaux
c'est une nécessité je crois qu'il faut
avoir des désirs du patriote je pense
qu'on a beaucoup de choses à dire on a
beau couple était entendu sur le thème
de la ruralité et vos commentaires marc
bien justement que dans les zones
rurales plus que dans les zones urbaines
et bien il ya une forte progression du
front national dans la nièvre finalement
sa cheminée d'érable gros duel entre le
ps et le front national dans l'yonne on
est à peu près dans un tiers des cantons
en tête
voilà donc ce sont des signes très
encourageants c'est la première partie
du match
nous allons conclure la semaine
prochaine on reviendra d'ailleurs les
estimations nationales patriat justement
sur ces estimations nationales
tout le monde parlait d'une déroute pour
la gauche dans fn très haut voire
premier parti trans qui n'est pas le cas
ce soir c'est une divine surprise où
c'est le travail d'un manuel valls par
exemple qu'on a beaucoup vu ces derniers
temps
d'abord ce qu'il faut dire ce soir c'est
que les actifs du sondages se sont
trompés
il avait dit changement de mode de
scrutin
changement de date de limite dans les
cantons les gens vont moins intéressés
il apparaît que il ya eu 8 % de plus de
votants 5 à 8% depuis votre donc les
gens sont allés voter je crois qu'ils
sont allés voter s'ils sont mobilisés et
en particulier parce que la gauche était
un niveau que certains n'annoncez pas
c'est plutôt parce que là il ya eu un
travail fait que les témoins de la
majorité présidentielle deuxième chose
contrairement à ce que j'entends
l'instant on nous donnait quoi comme
chiffres avant premier parti de france
le fn à 30 il est à 22 on disait
deuxième parti de france l'ump ps 28
il est à 33 on disait troisième parti de
france à 20 le ps il est à 28 mans donc
26 26 vas-y 7
voyez total donc voilà c'est pas du tout
ce qu'on disait le fn ce soir n'est pas
le premier parti de france
les deux parties qui sont en tête si les
partis républicains et moi c'est déjà
une satisfaction
ensuite ensuite les parties oui je pense
que les parties aient bien je pense que
lorsque le pasa parti républicain voilà
je liés il n'a pas les valeurs de la
république premier n'a pas les valeurs
de laïcité il n'a pas les valeurs les
valeurs que regretter qu'un partage je
le dis sans suite proximité je me le
dise que je finis le dicible des
guerriers parce que proximité nommé
intimité ce soir les élus de proximité
non ménagers soit les les élus fn qui
votent au 2è tour ne sont en aucun cas
des élus de proximité
je prends le canton où j'habite les deux
élus on les a jamais vus dans le canton
d'envoyer au livre la proximité on voit
bien que là c'est un score national sur
un mot d'ordre national sur les tracts
nationaux et après tout je vois que dans
la bourgogne bien la gauche résiste
plutôt bien
on sait pas ce qu'il adviendra de la
saône et loire mais dans la nièvre il
semble que la gauche garder la majorité
qu'en côte-d'or elle résiste plutôt bien
dans la nièvre vidéo semble que les
choses pratiques et de campagne pour nom
mais le disque est rien françois patriat
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus d'arguments je
pense qu'aujourd'hui
manuel valls taubira et hollande sont
aujourd'hui on dit en grande difficulté
dire que le front national n'est pas un
parti républicain s'est une fois de plus
insulter les électeurs les électeurs
patriotes
vous avez été quand même le ministre du
collaborateur françois mitterrand qui
portait la francisque alors ne parlez
pas de républicanisme
moi tout ce que je peux dire c'est que
ce soir en bourgogne il ya un grand élan
qui est né un grand élan patriote nous
avons eu des résultats extraordinaires
des résultats inattendus je crois que on
va montrer que le front national au
second tour a encore beaucoup de choses
à dire et surtout faire enfin entrer des
candidats patriotes dont nos conseils
départementaux nationale détaillera pas
ce canton petit qu'étonnant sur les
autres tout le monde et gagner ce soir
c'est quand même le comble le parti
sonia
le parti socialiste est en déroute
toujours d accord là dessus je crois que
françois que prévu on peut toujours
effectivement mettre la petite dose mais
très honnêtement c'est une sanction pour
le gouvernement de manuel valls est
évident mais ça on le savait déjà je
crois que les sondages le disais on peut
à un moment déterminé dire que la nièvre
reste à gauche mais historiquement j'ai
payé pour le savoir ça q c'est le jour
où la gauche majoritaire ne sera plus
majoritaires la droite il fut trahi il y
avait un député socialiste autrefois il
s'appelait françois patriat donc on est
dans un contexte effectivement les
choses n'évoluent pas dans le sens
effectivement d'un scrutin favorable au
parti socialiste et je crois par contre
il ya une déshérence et on le voit bien
dans les zones rurales électorat est
troublé et vote aux extrêmes simplement
parce que il est découragée par la
politique qui est menée et donc on verra
ce qui se passera dimanche prochain je
crois que c'est quand même très
difficile pour le parti socialiste dans
ce département est peut-être en
saône-et-loire de mots-clés cas dimanche
prochain de dire que c'est une grande
victoire pour eux c'est vrai que manuel
valls a failli et que les taubira et
d'autre aujourd'hui les françaises et
les français on est carrément ce qu'ils
en pensaient on va continuer dans un
instant un résultat qui vient de tomber
sur la côte d'or un message très
important très attendu s'attendait
nationale et des essais le cap de le
front national est à 39 44 % des voix
mais ce sera une triangulaire avec
emmanuelle coint gilles delepau pour
l'ump alain becquet et chantal bouveret
pour le ps divers gauche élections
auxerre ne sommes pas encore allés dans
l'yonne de 20h30 sur france 3 bourgogne
auxerre nathalie baye faire avec et des
résultats sur votre département nathalie
oui absolument nous avons à présent huit
résultats définitifs et dans ces huit
cantons le front national sera présent
au second tour quasiment à chaque fois
ce sera des duels avec la droite sauf
dans un cas avec la gauche et je
commence donc par le contenant de
joux-la-ville c'est le canton du
président sortant andré vigne est
associé à kohl et narbonne il arrive en
tête avec 41,24 % des suffrages
il sera donc opposé au fn gérard de
martini
divine bourgeois à saint-florentin même
cas de figure donc mais là c'est le
front national qui est nettement en tête
avec mehdi barbeau et isabelle chagnon
qui obtiennent 35,49 % des suffrages qui
sera opposé donc audio et udi gérard
andré et marie laure capitan qui
obtiennent 20,26 % des suffrages duel là
aussi donc à migennes françois boucher
le sortant ump arrive en tête avec 32,97
% des suffrages
une courte tête en face au fn 32 26
duels ump/fn là aussi à torigni soit
heureuse
même cas de figure duel ump fn le fn qui
obtient là un très gros score également
41 56% des suffrages avant celle de la
même façon c'est le front national qui
est en tête avec 27 59% des suffrages
mais là ce sera un duel donc avec la
gauche que 10,6 vecten un sortons
associé à christiane lemoine à charny le
front national et la hausse il a
nettement en tête avec 39 2 59% des
suffrages
il sera donc opposé au sortant william
lemaire 37,26 % william lemaire e ump et
puis enfin en cuisez le canton de coeur
de puiser c'est là aussi le front
national qui arrive en tête 34,28 % qui
sera opposé donc au duo ump pascal
bourgeois il avait le froment meurice
qui obtient 25 20 18 % des suffrages
merci nathalie d'affaires depuis auxerre
département où les électeurs se sont le
plus mobilisés en bourgogne un
commentaire edouard ferrand sur ses
résultats et de force corps pour votre
parti front national donc oui nous
sommes pratiquement en tête dans huit
cantons et en second tour dans un
certain nombre d'autres
ça montre que voilà on a bien travaillé
j'ai essayé de bien cording coordonnées
cette campagne et je pense que ça a
porté ses fruits
et c'est vraiment les fruits d'un
enracinement je crois qu'il ya un vote
d'adhésion c'est pas un vote de sanction
c'est un vraiment un vote d'adhésion
parce que nous sommes un département
très rural
la première qu'on aura que trois villes
qui dépasse dix mille habitants et je
crois qu'il ya une véritable attente
justement des gens de des icaunais vers
un véritable changement
youn a été classé le département le
moins bien gérées de france
je trouve qu'il ya une
sanction justement contre l'exécutif
alors on nous dit dans l'oreillette que
julien houle nous envoyer un texto pour
dire qu'il était aussi osons au second
tour dans le canton de pont sur yonne
qui est un canton sur lequel je crois
vous misez beaucoup une question edouard
ferrand vous êtes en tête vous êtes au
deuxième tour dont je crois oui quand on
on peut penser que le front national va
entrer au conseil général de l'yonne au
conseil départemental pardon est ce que
vous faites partie de ceux qui
souhaitent que le programme du front
national sur un certain nombre de points
soit appliquée dans les conseils
départementaux ou pas d'ailleurs dans
les débats qu'on a eues ici sur ce
plateau on a tout entendu certains qui
voulaient l'appliquer fortement d'autres
pas je pense par exemple à l'accueil des
mineurs étrangers isolés qui fait partie
des du des compétences des conseils
départementaux est ce que la préférence
nationale pour vous ça va s'imposer dans
le traitement du social dans le
traitement du rsa par exemple il y aura
un véritable changement et c'est sûr que
nous allons justement appuyé sur ses sur
ses points forts
ce qui est sûr c'est que y'a un sondage
qui tombait juste avant les élections
départementales qui montrent que 73 %
des administrés dans les communes gérées
par front national trouve que c'est une
bonne gestion mais je trouve que voilà
bon an mal an nous faisons notre petit
bonhomme de chemin
nos idées avancent mais aussi nous
allons montrer nos compétences
c'est-à-dire qu'une fois aux affaires
que ce soit dans les conseils généraux
ou dans les conseils régionaux et bien
le front national veut montrer qu'il a
des hommes des hommes nouveaux des
hommes de qualité on avait des chefs
d'entreprise on avait des des
commerçants on avait des gens que de
grande qualité ce qui explique également
que nos candidats ont montré un
véritable visage et une véritable
efficacité pour pour leur campagne
françois patriat donc le front national
sera donc de nombreux duels dans l'yonne
principalement contre des forces de
droite est ce que vous appelez la gauche
à voter pour les candidats de la droite
pour ce qui me concerne je pense tu
seras le fait la gauche et lady
républicaine il n'y a pas aucune
question à se poser
nous appellerons à voter pour le
candidat de la droite républicaine
les choses soient claires je reviens je
reviens à l'instant en arrière en jeu
dès que je parle le mps aller les
basques très bien finie nous appellerons
à voter pour eux n'auraient plus qu'à
moi je le dis il n'y a pas de nini on
vote pas pour ni ni vote pour quelqu'un
et le choix pour nous est que je sois
que deuxièmement la mobilisation
s'aperçoit qu'à mobilisation là profit
et à deux parties d'abord elle a profité
à la gauche c'est vrai qui est au dessus
du score qui était prévu par tous les
instituts de sondage
la profiter elle a profité dans certains
départements nos lionnes au front
national
ce qu'on voit que ce sursaut de
participation mais le front national
très haut mais je ne vois pas encore
aujourd'hui clairement des cantons
basculent et au front national
en tout cas pour la côte d'or où le
redoutait on le redoutait pour brazza et
qui semble que demain d'ailleurs retombe
pas et ne passera pas au front national
je l'espérais mais ça c'est vous le
redoutez vous anglais je le dis
aujourd'hui vous aider dans votre dos
liestal je dis que je redoute donc il
semble dans le dos même si les
relationnel
le front national est moins haut que
prévu il est moins de voir tout ça fait
avec 40% à bruxelles il est moi ou que
prévu en france 3 son monospace que
prévu en automne ses organes il est
moins haut que prévu en bordel c'est
clair on nous l'annonçait partout à plus
de 30%
il ne l'est pas il ne l'est pas c'est
clair donc c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
nous ce serait une claque une
mobilisation sur le banc lieu vous aller
vous allez faire la preuve en est un et
vous aurez choisi
mais voilà son 103e de nommer c'est
difficile d'en montrer que non seulement
vous n'êtes pas républicain oui c'est
quand vous ne savez pas débattre
loyalement avec celle que les élections
on entende bien chez lui les électeurs
dans les biens pour des montants compris
entre soit fausse oxo 17
il faut sanctionner le ps en bourgogne
dernière chose
jamais le parti au pouvoir la gagner
facilement les élections intermédiaires
jamais est rappelons le ce soir le parti
au pouvoir c'est la gauche elle
enregistre ce soit un recul c'est vrai
mais elle n'enregistre pas une défaite
lourde
elle résiste bien dans tout le
territoire français on l'a vu ici et
notamment en bourgogne on l'avait prévu
des de voir disparaître
on avait dit la versement des
départements régions bourgogne franche
comté
je pense qu'on ne sera pas le cas mais
quand même une question supplémentaire
par rapport à braser justement la
question devra sans doute se poser quand
le front national est grosso modo à à
40% emmanuelle coint et son binôme à à
30 5 septembre à dire et la gauche est
bien en dessous à 22 24
qu'est ce qu'elle doit faire la question
va se poser demain des matières du
candidat je vous rappelle que à semur en
auxois dans un cas de figure peu près
identique
jay leno s'était retiré pour faire
passer mme adams à dos parce que parce
qu'il y avait un risque à l'époque de
voir le mr qui étaient proches du front
national réélu demain on va rejoindre
on va en parler ce soir et demain
on verra si la situation est dangereuse
dans ses coffres dans ces conditions
nous ne ferons pas c'est le candidat de
la droite républicaine
une question pour l'insuline au parlant
de l'yonne alors vous connaissez bien la
nièvre voilà et la côte d'or mais une
question sur l'yonne de s'y faire on
s'en doute c'est un département très
marqué à droite
historiquement depuis toujours on sait
qu'aujourd'hui l'yonne a beaucoup voté
par rapport à d'autres départements ont
ses clients votent toujours beaucoup
dans les situations où la droite est en
tête dans les élections pourraient
reprendre les élections cantonales de 92
à 2011 systématiquement vague bleue
l'yonne vote beaucoup quand la gauche
dominion vote moins que les autres
départements bourguignons le sens de ma
question c'est on voit beaucoup de front
national qualifié pour le deuxième tour
dans l'yonne
est ce que c'est un département qui
illustre une forme de porosité ou deux
en tout cas de développement d'un
électorat front national sur ce qu'était
un électorat de droite traditionnelle
avant les élections départementales ce
sont aussi des élections de proximité
même si les français ont rien compris
probablement et avec raison au découpage
qu'ils ont subi mais c'est vrai que il
ya aussi un précédent au niveau du
département
je crois que les mêmes causes produisent
les mêmes effets je pense que ce
département a eu des difficultés et le
vote de souffrance que l'on constate
dans l'yonne qui existent aussi ailleurs
sur d'autres territoires
je crois qu'il faut pas se tromper
dimanche prochain il faut bien sûr que
ce soit un vote concret par rapport à
des vrais projets il est question vous
posiez de terre soit intéressante pour
ça quelles sont les réponses du front
national je crois que quand j'entends le
président du conseil régional vous dire
que des territoires qui était bien
évident des territoires gérés par des
socialistes on parle tout à l'heure du
val de saône il est évident que le
candidat socialiste soit le troisième
c'est bien la preuve qu'il ya bien sûr
un échec et un constat d'échec qu'on
pourra pas dire je me répète un peu mais
que c'est une victoire aujourd'hui
mais pour l'yonne effectivement il ya eu
il ya une souffrance et il ya
certainement un désir d'autre chose et
cette autre chose c'est bien sûr à nos
amis à ma famille politique de leur
présenter demain avec des candidats qui
peut être pourront tirer un trait sur un
passé qui a été difficile on est
d'accord c'est à paris qu'elle dans
l'yonne je crois qu'il ya effectivement
inscrits à particulier ça ne sera pas le
cas je pense ne pas me tromper en saône
et loire puisque je pense qu'on va
conquérir ce ce département ce sera ne
pas le cas bien sûr en côte d'or
on verra tout à l'heure la conservation
mais je pense que la côte d'or la le
parti socialiste s'effondre pour part
pour être gentil il n'empêche que ce
sera probablement la nièvre n'est pas
une surprise ce sera pas le cas dans
l'yonne en tous les cas avec de grandes
difficultés
19h45 les premiers résultats donc vous
les avez depuis une demi heure
maintenant sur france 3 bourgogne vous
les retrouvez sur notre site internet
vous pouvez également participer via les
réseaux sociaux et commenter ces
résultats
nous repartons à nevers où nous attend
régis guillon pour de nouveaux résultats
régis wii commence à faire beaucoup de
bruit ici là nous sommes dans la
préfecture de la nièvre
les esprits s'échauffent un peu ça
s'anime alors d'abord un rectificatif
qui concerne le canton de corbigny je
vous annonçais un duel pour dimanche
prochain bien non c'est une triangulaire
qui s'annonce avec arrivée en tête je
voulais dit le binôme de droite suivie
par le binôme socialiste en tout cas le
binôme qui représente conseil général
avec son candidat
fabien bazin et puis alors le troisième
binôme c'est bien le binôme du front
national incarner lui par le patron du
fn yèvre marcel stéphan est par ailleurs
vous savez conseiller régional voilà
donc une triangulaire sur ce canton de
corbigny avec la droite la gauche et le
fn sans doute en arbitre et puis y
sommes un résultat qui ne parvient aussi
qui concerne le canton de clamecy là
c'est bien un duel mais sans la gauche
sanctionné puisque le conseiller général
sortant qui incarnait le binôme de
gauche au bénin
ne passez pas ce premier tour un premier
tour pas dès que la droite
d'abord la droite avec 30 points 36% et
puis ensuite le fn là aussi donc un duel
droite front national sur ce canton de
clamecy
merci régis trilles nous partons pour
mâcon à présent priorité résultats
damien bouthillier résultats pour la
saône-et-loire
oui alors déjà deux duels droite extrême
droite notamment à la chapelle de
guinchay tout à l'heure où la dissidence
de gérard voisin ne sait absolument pas
passées comme prévu puisqu'il arrive
avant dernier avec 12 95% ce sera
finalement un duel donc droite extrême
droite entre le fn carole à la mercerie
et serge papillon 29,28 face à jean
françois cognard et madame dominique
pierre 27,21 également tournus nous
partons également sur un duel droite
extrême droite toujours avec l'union
départementale la droite qui arrive 36
53 %
pour jean claude becousse et colette
betchen suivi par le front national
dominique marchal et daniel perret
ensuite direction mâcon par ayew la
dissidence de droite n'a pas fonctionné
jean philippe belleville fait 5,22 % des
exprimés
finalement c'est florence battard de
l'ump udi avec jacques tournis qui
arrive en tête 36 24 suivi par le ps tu
es fatigué et joël martiaux 27,34 % et
puis ouroux sur saône une nouvelle
triangulaire avec en premier le binôme
du parti socialiste 36,02 suivi de la
droite 34,26 et puis le front national
se classe 3e 29,73 % on retourne dans
les deux classiques notamment sur autun
1 avec catherine amyot et frédéric
brochot qui arrive en tête 50,68 % mais
ils n'ont pas 25% des inscrits donc
deuxième tour pour eux face au divers
gauche qui se présente avec 27,87 % et
puis à gueugnon dominique lotte arrive
en tête avec sa colistière 40,5 mais il
part pour un deuxième tour face à la
droite 24,86 pour ça merci damien
bouthillier pour la saône et loire avec
29 cantons nous partons pour la
côte-d'or en direct de la préfecture de
dijon pour retrouver l les diriger avec
plusieurs résultats ont déjà pour le
canton de montbard on s'attendait à un
gros affrontement gauche droite assez
rude eh bien on voit que c'est l'union
de la droite qui est en tête notamment
ce sera un duel pour le coup 19,70 % en
faveur du tandem marc frot et laurence
porte patrick molinoz zh et marion
mongouachon pour le rassemblement de
gauche sont juste derrière 18,36 2% donc
un duel pour ce canton de montbard le
front national étant exclues de ce
premier tour a très très peu
d'intervalle à 11 57 % des inscrits pour
ce résultat là voilà ce qu'on peut dire
sur montbard on va regarder ensuite ce
qui se passe du côté du canton de genlis
là aussi score relativement serré même
très très serré avec un front national
qui se trouve en tête cette fois ci
françoise beaudoin eric tallec 17 94 %
des inscrits talonné un peu de choses
près par l'union de la droite vincent
dancourt et christelle méheut 17,70 là
non plus pas de gauche qui s'installent
pour ce deuxième tour des
départementales autres résultats
toujours châtillon-sur-seine là aussi
assez peu de surprise finalement c'est
la droite qui est très largement en tête
valérie bouchard et hubert brigand
conseiller général sortant 50 presque 53
% à exprimer 27 73%
donc pour ce tandem et puis là aussi le
front national au second tour pour
batailler derrière tout de même martine
rossi ambroise savatier avec 16
25% des voix enfin on termine avec le
canton d'is sur tille des résultats
aussi donc qui viennent juste de nous
parvenir et bien là on va avoir droit à
une triangulaire avec en tête la droite
charles barrière et catherine louis 24
61 % le front national christian benard
chantal lamboley 14,92 % et enfin
l'union de la gauche ça passe aussi
claude bellot et philippe michaud voilà
ce qu'on pouvait dire en tout cas pour
ces quatre nouveaux cantons pour la côte
d'or merci les journaux donc une
élection au premier tour sur le canton
de châtillon sur seine
hubert brigand est élu avec valérie
bouchard avec 52 68 pour un canton qui
est donc renouvelée donc au premier tour
puisque rappelle pour avoir à l'élection
au premier tour il faut la majorité et
25% des inscrits nous partons notre tour
d'horizon continue en bourgogne avec et
auxerre et d'autres résultats avec vous
nathalie baffert absolument 3 à nouveau
quand on est toujours le même scénario
le front national qui sera au second
tour dans des duels face à la gauche
à joigny puisque le duo fn claire dior
armelle garni obtient arrive en tête 31
34% d'une très courte tête devant le
mino mme soutenue par le parti
socialiste nicolas soret et françois
bourque qui obtiennent 31 20 duels fn/ps
donc à joigny dans le tonnerrois le
canton du tonnerrois s'est lui dit
maurice pianon associé à anne jérusalem
qui arrive en tête avec 32 92 % des
suffrages et il sera opposé au second
tour au binôme fn jacques coutela
sandrine n'ayant ce 30,92 à chablis même
cas de figure de nouveau là c'est le
vice-président actuel de
l'assemblée départementale patrick
gendraud de droite donc qui obtient 45
points 53% des suffrages
il sera donc opposé au duel front
nationaux du au pardon front national
alexandre à la faille que et charles
bertholet et puis je découvre à
l'instant un compte en urbain avec
auxerre 1
là ce sera en revanche un duel ps ump
c'est l'ump valérie le j'ai associé à
michel ducroux qui arrive en tête avec
35,31 % des suffrages devant donc le
binôme socialiste guy parisse sortons
associé à kristin lehman courcy merci
nathalie d'affaires depuis auxerre à la
pour ces résultats que nous commentons
avec nos invités
elle voulait bien me l'ait on peut
prendre un exemple donc nathalie vient
de parler c'est le canton de joany c'est
assez particulier puisque là on y lit la
guerre entre l'ump le président hu dei
du conseil général andré villiers avait
des candidats udi des candidats ump
finalement ni l'ump ni lui d in est au
deuxième tour on va avoir un deuxième
tour entre le front national et le
candidat du parti socialiste nicolas
soret ce qui nous amène à une question
pour jouer à l'insu de noël vous vous
doutiez que j'allais vous la poser
françois patriat s'est exprimé tout à
l'heure sur ce type de situation qui
pouvait concerner candidats douch
n'était pas au deuxième tour
quelle est votre position avoue que doit
faire les candidats de l'ump elle est
même seule udi par les mots casion de
votre point de vue je crois que nicolas
sarkozy avait été clair y compris avant
un certain bureau qui avait défrayé la
chronique
je pense que les électeurs sont majeurs
sur ce territoire et dans cette
hypothèse
je ne suis pas personnellement un adepte
du ni ni
je pense que le front républicain a vécu
aussi il n'empêche que nos électeurs
choisiront je pense qu'elles vont
déterminer où on fait le choix dit
républicain qui veut que françois
patriat tout à l'heure dans cette
hypothèse ça concernant conscience des
électeurs
si on ne souhaite pas que hay et d'élus
du front national au niveau
départemental c'est un choix personnel
donc chacun sur la baie conscience
votera il est bien évident que nous ne
donnerons pas en tous les cas de mots
d'ordre de vote systématique par un port
sd par tom jobim
je suis choquée parce que quand on dit
que lecteur elle va le choix bien
entendu la liberté lecteurs mais nous
nous sommes élus nous sommes dans des
partis politiques
nous donnons des consignes nous allons
des réunions dont le faire des meetings
le rend leur dira rien on leur dira
faites ce que vous voulez choisissant
votre votre âme et conscience
ça veut dire que on prend le risque
demain d'avoir effectivement des élus du
front national le procès général j'en ai
quelques uns conseil régional je peux
vous dire ce qu'il en est d'ailleurs on
est à ma gauche un instant moi je
considère que cette position qui est
quand même le ni ni voté comme vous
voulez n'est pas une position
républicaine quand on a un parti qui est
en face qui est xénophobe qu'on a un
parti qui est raciste quand un parti qui
n'est pas républicain de laisser le
choix aux électeurs
bien sûr que les électeurs si vous êtes
insultant faut-il encore je lui dit vous
êtes insultant parce que c'est la
réalité et le peuple
je pense que le peuple c'est pas le
peuple mais le real va s'en souvenir et
dimanche page de la naissance il avoué
au ps et notamment un jury manip séchage
les forces il faut j'appelle les
patriotes de joie ni de se poser contre
l'inconnu d'un collapsus et bien qu'ils
aient déjà de haine le parti socialiste
vous avez la défaite amère gens qui
républicain j'ai dit oui mais non mais
pas des maisons vous employez des
qualifications à des qualificatifs qui
sont honteux de la part de responsables
politiques
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
fait votre temps il est temps de sortir
les sortants le ni ni ne sert à rien
aujourd'hui on a bien vu et compris dans
les élections d'aujourd'hui si vous
aviez un panini ya vingt-deux souffrance
y avait deux souffrent je l'évoquais
tout à l'heure je crois que nos
électeurs des électeurs soit assez grand
aujourd'hui 6 exprima vote à travers un
vote front national est ce que c'est à
votre conscience d'adhésion je ne ne
crois pas en tous les cas pour cette
échéance là c'est la raison pour
laquelle si c'est pas une adhésion une
voix ce qui leur reste à faire
n'empêche que je ne vois pas comment un
responsable politique aujourd'hui de
l'ump peut sereinement dire vous devez
voter telle et telle manière ce temps là
est révolu vous réserve de voix sous le
seront ils dans l'yonne c'est une
dynamique fantastique que monsieur
patriat ne veut pas voir mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui les socialistes n'existe
plus dans l'yonne
aujourd'hui au conseil général il y aura
peut-être un voire deux conseillers
départementaux socialiste vous visiez 5
pour vous m'écoutez invités sous savoir
n'a pas encore le canton de pont sur
yonne
mais à la vitesse où ça va on va être en
tête dans au moins dix cantons sur 21 ce
qui ne veut pas dire vous auriez il mais
c'est non mais cette année c'est une
dynamique assez incroyable assez
improbable moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui
l'enseignement c'est justement de monter
le front national sur ses terres la
devance largement alors que c'est d'un
conseil général sortant de droite le
front national s'impose contre des
conseillers généraux sortants qui était
quand même bien ancrés bien enracinés
dans leur compte aux avec nous des
candidats qu'ils ont montrée justement
leur capacité à pouvoir justement arrivé
en tête sur le canton de joie ni
particulièrement c'est une ville tenue
par la gauche ou le président de la
communauté de communes par ces arrivées
en tête et bien non c'est le candidat du
front national qui se retrouvera
aujourd'hui en position je pense d'être
élu c'est ce que titrait d'ailleurs le
monde qui disait juste avant les
élections qu'il y aurait au moins
content au front national pour avoir un
élu dans l'yonne c'est celui johnny mme
je suis très fier du résultat d'armes un
dernier éclair dur sur ce canton et pour
faire quoi là bas attendait aujourd'hui
nous avons peu près un cas de figure où
on nous avons à peu près huit candidats
en position d'être élu et bien 8000
candidats sur 21 vous voyez que c'est
une condition que les électeurs de
droite votent pour vous donc c'est ça
que vous appelez de ce savoureux
non mais il n'y a pas une ville comme
jeunes une ville comme usa on arrive en
tête michel 709 ferroviaire qu'elle en
tête l'entente était communiste
vous imaginez pas que les électeurs de
droite votent pour nous aujourd'hui il
ya une dynamique lancée par marine le
pen à la fois sur la droite et sur la
gauche
tous les les ouvriers et les classes
moyennes et populaires déçu par parti
socialiste parce que parti socialiste
aujourd'hui utilisé lectorat immigrés
pour essayer de pour faire des forces
d'appoint
eh bien ces gens là abandonné lâché par
le gouvernement de valls et hollande
et bien aujourd'hui se réfugient dans
les thèmes du front national et michel
est la caractéristique même d'une ville
ouvrière qui a été communiste et qui
aujourd'hui met en tête un candidat du
front national
le vote migrer j'ai pas bien compris la
sita a priori les heats s'enchaînent ce
cas le droit de vote
non parce que monsieur cambadélis disait
qu'on faisait les fontes poubelles pour
trouver nos candidats ce qui est comme
monsieur patriat oui le parti société
très amer aujourd'hui
vraiment on est on peut voir le vrai
visage du parti socialiste qui ce qu'ils
s'attaquent non pas aux idées mais mais
mais aux hommes c'est bien
eh bien on montre aujourd'hui que nos
candidats bien non seulement on les a
pas trop bien écouler mais sont de
qualité et aujourd'hui je peux vous dire
ils vont faire vaciller plus d'un
contondant dans le département de
l'yonne et en bourgogne ne sont quand
même pas très connu sur le terrain les
candidats du front national françois
disais tout à l'heure très honnêtement
la cour d'assises où alain suguenot
quand je vois que bfm business class le
département de l'yonne
le maître département le moins de boîtes
bien gérée de france que contribuables
associés
mais le département de l'yonne à un
niveau d'endettement trois fois
supérieurs à la moyenne des départements
français ben moi je veux dire
aujourd'hui on a des candidats qui sont
quand même bien meilleur que tous ceux
là qui ont failli avec tous les
scandales qui vont qui vont sortir ce
notamment dans certains conseils
généraux voulait réagir pour sa patrie
hier 30 secondes seront terminés il
s'agit pas ici de stigmatiser des
électeurs qui pour des différentes
raisons vous savez les électeurs du
front national
se voit-il très protéiforme et des gens
qui viennent des classes aisées des
classes très pauvres du monde agricole
du monde paysan du monde ouvrier on le
sait bien aujourd'hui sans doute que
nous ne donnons pas toujours les bonnes
réponses
sans doute que dans un moment de crise
comme celui là avec un pays qui est au
bord de la faillite
d'un côté et que d'autre part à une
croissance zéro et les attentes qui ne
sont pas aujourd'hui satisfaite et qu'il
ya une forme de désespérance pas
seulement dans la campagne dans la ville
aussi dans la campagne comme on flatte
souvent des espérances des gens on
arrive à les faire voter front national
mais avouez que les gens qui ont voté
front national n'ont pas voté pour des
candidats de proximité qu'il ne
connaissait pas et qu'il n'avait jamais
vu donc quand on fait un appel à la
proximité de la mer
je pense qu'il n'y a pas là un vote
d'adhésion au titre personnel s'ils font
ça on va partir à nevers tout de suite
pour un résultat celui de l'élection
municipale cette fois de
varennes-vauzelles puisque les électeurs
votaient pour les départementales et des
municipales aujourd'hui où effectivement
alors attention ce
on pas des résultats officiels n'ont pas
encore été validés par la préfecture ils
sont officieuse donc comme on dit mais
la victoire est acquise par la liste de
la maire sortante isabelle bonicel
contre une liste un peu gauche plurielle
emmené par les communistes les
socialistes et europe ecologie les verts
isabelle bonicel donc élu sa liste élue
avec 60% des voix contre 40% pour la
liste d'olivier s'y colle avec un écart
d'un peu plus de 1000 voix voilà merci
régis millions depuis 9h nous y
reviendrons bien évidemment la soirée
continue sur france 3 bourgogne avec un
maximum de résultats pour ces élections
elles départemental nous allons faire
une synthèse de des résultats au niveau
national avec et les estimations france
télévisions vous pouvez également
retrouver tous nos résultats sur notre
site internet france3 point fr nous
continuons la discussion et d'autres
résultats évidemment à partir de 21h15
vous serez là bien évidemment pour la
suite de cette soirée spéciale sur
france3 la seule chaîne à vous proposer
une soirée spéciale élections
départementales tout de suite carole
gaessler et francis letellier
à tout à l'heure dans un quart d'heure